ladies and gentlemen welcome to Gamespot
HQ here at E3 2015 for our Microsoft
press conference pre-show I'm Chris
Waters joining me here on stage is Rob
Crossley good to be here good to see you
rob Tamor Hussein hello hello my friend
and Kevin vanord why hi there gentlemen
we have gathered to uh discuss the
Microsoft press conference things we
know that are going to be there things
we hope will be there and things that uh
they really should shouldn't have there
uh so let's start off with uh you know
we saw games last night at Bethesda
press conference but one of the things
that distinguishes Microsoft is Hardware
they're going to talk about the Xbox one
they're going to talk about PCS uh what
do you think is going to be sort of
their big Hardware push for this press
conference I think it's going to be a
good opportunity for them to uh mention
that they've just announced a one
terabyte model of it so hopefully they
won't spend too long on that just a bit
this is here it cost this much dollars
go and buy it and I think it's like what
$50 more than the normal Xbox right yeah
that is true we're making some progress
on that front and uh moving on guys yeah
that's the Hope do you think they'll
even mention SS because I mean Mar have
been quite Co about Xbox One Sals the
whole time right I think I think they'll
they'll just be like we are doing great
everything is cool right yeah we're very
we are stay the course figured this
thing out you guys smile smile smile
we're just we're just not going to
mention any numbers yeah that's it yeah
we'll save the install base numbers for
Sony's press conference this evening
yeah exactly and that would be the smart
thing to do because you know is going to
come out there and be like we've got all
the numbers like they are well high
right now and so Microsoft just needs to
be like apple St like we're doing great
it's really good yeah well Microsoft in
the news last week of course with the
Oculus VR press conference uh it was
announced that Xbox One controller is
going to be bundled with the Oculus and
that uh it's you're going to be able to
play Xbox One games on your Oculus
through the PC in a kind of virtual
Cinema thing uh what do you guys think
are we going to see VR show up at the
Microsoft press conference today I think
they kind of obligated to reciprocate
right they've got to show it in some
capacity um no we believe in this too
it's not just those Oculus guys they
didn't just give us a huge bag of money
which is exactly what happens I I think
they're going to struggle showing off
that Ulus demo because essentially it's
just a 3D theater where you can play
Xbox One games I mean that's not good
right it's not we're not impressed by
that are we like echo of PlayStation
home like I'm going to go watch a movie
in virtual theater with people doing
weird dances in front of the screen then
again I mean they did that for Netflix
when it first launched on Xbox and
people were kind of into that the kind
of like viewing experience so maybe if
you could have like multiple people with
each with their Oculus Rifts sitting in
one place watch it sounds so dumb as I
am I can't even get through the mean
just playing on Xbox live together just
don't buy it just play your games on
your TV in front of your face okay but
uh you know one of the things that sort
of enables that Xbox One PC connectivity
is Windows 10 uh the full sort of
install of that is coming in just a
month or so uh Kevin vanord what do you
think in terms of the Xbox One PC
connectivity this is like sort of their
answer to Sony's Cross by ecosystem yeah
I'm actually really excited about that
as a PC Gamer sometimes you know as much
as I love the the whole steam turn it
into uh like kind of a console thing
there are times where I just rather play
the stuff like on a console you know
what I mean and like just sit down turn
on the Xbox One if it if it means not
having to switch back between screens
and having to to worry about that kind
of stuff I mean I'm I'm down for that
right yeah and I mean who isn't down for
Cross by crossplay and that kind of
streaming stuff that's something that
they I believe touched on last year a
little bit but I kind of expect them to
talk about it a little B more bit more
this year yeah I guess so I mean it's
it's it's a big selling point for both
XBox and and windows um on top of
obviously Candy Crush is now included
with Windows 10 as default so I'm hoping
they give that some time oh we that's
right well I mean we've seen threes on
the stage at Xbox press conference
before so who knows you never know could
happen but yeah how how big of a selling
point do you think that technology is
going to be the fact that you can stream
your Xbox One games to your PC is anyone
are we interested in that I mean
everyone thought that you know streaming
your PS4 game to vaita wouldn't be a big
thing and then they found you know that
sitting in bed and playing Destiny was
pretty Okay and like same with like
second screen Wii U stuff so I think it
might be one of those things where um
people appreciate it once it's out there
and they kind of have the situation
where it's actually working for them but
I mean I imagine it takes a pretty
powerful PC to you know make that work
right or a good Wi-Fi set and a good
Wi-Fi setup yeah there might be some
like technological stuff that could
cause a few issues but I'm personally as
someone who's just built a brand new pc
and is kind of just sitting there not
really with anything to play I'm kind of
excited about the idea of you know
streaming a game while my TV is busy
watching some other I guess it's a
massive convenience thing right because
if you buy a game you know you can sort
of play it in any room like where your
PC is and where your TV is I think
that's actually quite cool gives you
that flexibility that here to four Xbox
and Microsoft haven't really put on the
table uh speaking of something that they
haven't didn't really put on the table
last year connect last year's press
conference virtually devoid of any
mention of connect do you think we're
going to see them sorry what what is
connect say the K words Conn got connect
yeah it's the arm waggling one it's like
the Wii but you don't have to hold it
can you get it on Xbox One absolutely
what really yeah well it cost it's extra
it's not bundled with it anymore right
are there loads of games for it or games
for there's the there's the Wave Race
one listen crley you can tell it to do
things and it does it most of the time
true most of the time somebody's being
very uh I I you're being a little
bullish on this I when I do my American
accent it listens to me if I go full
English it's just like I'm not listening
to you one bit I I'm being really
cynical I actually really love using my
connect I use turn on the Xbox I used to
change channels and as as as stupid and
as small a thing that sounds it makes my
life so much easier so it makes it
easier walking into the room and going
Xbox on instead of pressing that button
you know you're queuing up the Netflix
thing while you're fixing your dinner
like something like that it sort of has
that utility but like in terms of games
and a gaming experience they've really
sort of distance themselves from that uh
I i' be very surprised if it sh
considering that their latest bundle
removes it
from from you know from being purchased
so I I very much doubt it's it's going
to be and they've got a new sexy
gimmicky thing to talk about in its
place Hollow l h lens yeah yep
interesting it's very interesting I
think it's quite like I'm I'm interested
it purely because it's so different from
everything else out there like everyone
is jumping on the VR train everyone has
a VR thing whereas they have their
they're kind of forcing everyone to have
a distinct conversation about their
thing cuz everyone else when they
discuss valves V are it's all in
comparison to each other like how does
it stack up to Oculus how does it stack
up to Morpheus you know how does it
stack up to Vive whereas these guys are
like you can't make that comparison it's
very much like when the Wii came out for
the first time it's like you can't
really compare the Wii to all the other
games cuz it's you know it's less
powerful and it's got this unique uh
input system so it's like you need to
have this kind of distinct conversation
about it and and that is commendable
that they do is commendable yeah whether
it actually amounts to anything good
that's still yet to be seen but
it's the execution for me I look I mean
all of this looks real cool and
everything when I see it on here but I
imagine when I actually get that headset
on and I'm looking around things are
kind of
wishy-washy and they're sort of jiggling
and not really moving the way I want
them to because it's not sticking to the
surface I want it to in the right way
and I look at this and think oh this
looks like the future and then I think
oh but as as as implemented it's not
going to be anything like the future
it's going to be this weird wacky thing
like a connect yeah given that that
history it is easy to be skeptical right
I'm very skeptical but I'm skeptical
about VR in general I think the reason
to be skeptical as well is because the
standards are so high like with with the
with the wi and with connect the problem
was that if any slight error happened if
there was some sort of artifact or if
there was some sort of problem then the
whole experience is ruined and with
something like Hollens which attempts to
resurface your entire room with like you
know these virtual objects that there's
a great chance that could mess up right
yeah it's tricky and I mean I think that
the one thing though that is interesting
about augmented reality versus virtual
reality is that you can put put your
little Hollow lens in front of the
camera lens and you can actually kind of
see a demo of it in something that
approximates what the product will be
whereas with VR you can't really like
looking at a VR thing of Eve Valkyrie or
a drift uh these games just looks like
another video game that you're floating
through space great doesn't approximate
the experience that makes that special
whereas perhaps if they get the demo
situation right we could see what makes
hollowland special yeah I mean I'm just
thinking back to the first time they
reveal connect and the ambitious like
the way they described it like there
going to be you know amazing
lifechanging experience and then when it
came out it was just like
rubbish well at first at first it was a
little bit flawed it wasn't Minority
Report generation one connect I'm
talking about Xbox 3 60 so I I but like
the second version of connect it
realizes what they originally intended
better it's just by that point they'd
kind of Poison the Well so I'm I'm a
little worried that they kind of will do
something similar they really need to
come out and make it work well from the
outset otherwise it could kind of
scramble their plans for the future if
you could have any game to Showcase
Holly lens what game if you were
Microsoft if you were Phil big Phil what
would you choose to flaunt hland I love
the idea that I'm big
Phil yeah resurrect Milo I mean I think
that's the way to that's the way to go
here Milo resurrect Milo it's got to be
Minecraft come on I surely they want to
go yeah it's going to be Minecraft but
like I think I reckon Halo Wars might be
a decent one great idea bring back Halo
War great even if it's just the original
version of Halo Wars just retrofitted to
be more like gesture based and touch
based or more recently Spartan Ops you
know sort of similar perspective yeah I
kind of like term based thing which
doesn't require a lot of quick movements
and isn't like timing based just so you
can like move things around
but even outside of that think of like
all the TV shows and all the games we
see where they just pull up virtual
screens and they're like you know
Splinter Cell seems kind of open for
something like that uh or like you know
in heavy rain when there's whole bits of
the game where you're doing that like
that's what i' love to see it for is
like bring you know bring these you know
machines that you know you you only see
in a Tom
Clancy kind of thing and bring that to
me that's that's what I'd like to see I
don't really care about like ver like I
can play Halo Wars I'm Just a Touch
controller or a controller bring me
something that makes me feel like I'm
actually in the future yeah I want a HD
an object game where it just hides
things around your house and you have to
zoom and enhance to locate them that's
pretty good okay I'm quite sold on this
H all right well we talked a bunch about
Hollow lens and all the hardware that we
might see at the Microsoft press
conference but now let's talk about the
games uh to more you said the h-word so
Halo 5 Guardians right I'm really
excited to see this I I didn't think I
would be I I enjoyed Halo 4 but it
wasn't like life-changing in the way
that Halo 3 was or even the first Halo
so I was kind of Wishy wasy on how how
much I'd be excited about it but then I
played the beta and the beta was I I
really got addicted to it I was
surprised how much I liked it yeah just
the small changes like the Vault and
mantle and stuff and the the charge it
basically felt like I was Samus for it
while just like arm charging everyone
and stuff like that but yeah I'm really
excited to see what they do with it and
the the kind of story is intriguing me
again for the first time in a long time
like being hunted by another group of
you know Spartans and the return of
Nathan fillian that's that's getting me
you want like I Buck his back and he's
out to kill my mief yeah I definitely
think they're going to lean into that
storyline here you know of course we saw
a lot of footage coming out of the
multiplayer beta we got a good look at
sort of the some of the stuff they're
trying with mobility and the new sort of
modes and focus on Esports uh but I
think big part of the Microsoft press
conference is going to be about that
Halo 5 story is going to be about the
sort of the I don't know like this
almost this gaming taboo of like wait
Master Chief like isn't the unmitigated
good guy isn't like like there is
another perspective you know they tease
that a little bit in Halo 4 sort of this
sort of obsolescence of the Spartan 2os
and uh or you know Master Chief sort of
era of Spartans but I think they're
going to get really into it this time
around hopefully they don't go into like
the TV realm and talk about Nightfall
too much and just show us a campaign
level show us what it's like to play has
Spartan lock if that's at all different
you know how that works out uh all right
so Halo 5 Guardians obviously going to
be a big push let's talk about some
other exclusives that we are expecting
to see we hope to see anybody have any
on their radar um there's going to be
that rumors of a uh rare collection
that's right that looks that that's
interesting I think the Microsoft have
finally decided that they should
probably stop like hurting everyone with
their treatment over R making them do
like a s and stuff like that like
remember these guys used to make awesome
games that people loved right um so
let's bring push those back to the
Forefront so how is this going to work
is this going to be like an arcade
collection of like 64 bit and 16 bit
games or I apparently it seems like it's
a HD upgrade of all like banjo and blast
cor and and all these other class batt
toads yeah battle toads I think a lot of
people are romanticizing their uh their
love of battle toads I don't know if
you've played battle toads recently it
is not good that game is not enjoyable
to yeah it's cool when your foot becomes
a giant Boot and it like is a heavy hit
but like man if there is a remake of
blast cor I'm going to be so happy yeah
I I will yeah you and about four other
people me too if you haven't played
blast C before it's like it's one of the
greatest games of all time it's
absolutely amazing absolutely loved it
so I would love to see a remake Rob says
that about everything he had had a bowl
of corn flakes this morning he's like
this is the greatest bowl of corak you
haven't had Corn Flakes yet I just
stress enough corol flakes but is this
really a good use of rare's talent at
this stage this is what's getting me too
us oh we're finally moving them off of
avatars we're finally not forcing them
to do like all these connect games so
let's resurrect the old catalog but
we'll continue to let your actual
talents languish your actual creativity
we're just going to shove that in a
closet think it's a perfect use of rare
talents because if you list the games
that are indicative of rare's talents
it's these games
viata like came they made I think the
question's more complex than that though
because this has been going on for like
15 years and this is more about
Personnel than it is about Direction the
people who have the people who make you
know those sports
games that's what that's sports that is
how you
Sports you know there connect sports
games there are people that have been
hiring inter it and the people that made
the hardcore awesome amazing games
they're now plon making yeah that's
that's that's a big problem like you we
have to remember that we don't know
whether is actually rare making these
games it could be outsourced or
something I think Microsoft has finally
realized that you know project ukulele
has come along and it's basically eating
their lunch like this they are trading
off the Nostalgia for rare to kind of
propel their new game um and it's
working amazingly so I think this is an
effort from Microsoft to kind of try and
take back some of their ident from uh
projects like project ukulele and other
games that are kind of trading off their
their kind of the buzz that they gave
people when they were young so maybe
maybe this won't be an amazing like
brand new game but it's certainly going
somewhere into restoring some of the
identity of that that studio I'll give
them that I'm just always somebody
craving something that you know that new
thing craving a new thing like a new
Gears of War Kevin vanord yes why yes
but aren't is isn't the whole thing
going to be that the isn't the rumor is
just that we're getting like uh HD Gears
of War I well I think they'll do what
everyone else is doing now uh HD
Collection this fall new gears next fall
how about that all right all right I I
will take that if that's what I'm
getting I reckon we'll see a lot of a
gameplay of the gears HD and then we'll
see a short trailer or a teaser for for
the new gears non Gameplay trailer of
the new gears because it's too it's far
too early in development for to have
anything right now it's going to be
Marcus Phoenix all old looking like
melting Arnold Scher just coming
out oh he's going to do the Han Solo
he's just going to come around at the
end and be like d we're
home Dom is going to go my wife is still
not here with me dang it uh yeah all
right so any guesses about like new
Gears of War is it going to be before
emergence day after after you know
they've sort of dealt with the Locust
threat any any Gears of War fans want to
make a deep guess or should we move on
to it's so hard to guess where where
they can take it because at the same
time as wrapping up the story it's kind
of also a boring story like it's done I
was I was going to say did G have a
story it had a story there was a the
clothes man my wife my wife it was it
was about a b moment was yeah there was
that M which was which was followed by
Easter egg where he shouts who wants
toast like his wife his wife is just
moments ago dead and then you go into
the next room and there's a toaster
there and heats up the toast and he goes
who wants toast and then Dom comes in
having just mourned his wife says I like
it
crispy it's like d trying to regain some
semblance of normaly we all grieve in
different ways all right so Gears of War
definitely going to see something on
that I mean here's hoping uh Fable
Legends they announced it last year
maybe G to see that a little bit Kevin
vanord not too psyched about it I played
some of that
game I think I think I think that game
we really but I I think that game has a
bit of an identity problem I think that
it has a better chance of being good
that m andu is off doing something else
whoa I think someone I was being har
pathological liar I wouldn't say I'd say
he's he's ambitious to the point where
he's like he gets out of control so like
there's not that kind of one name like
power in there that can just derail
entire project they have the opportunity
to come and be like Focus this make this
a good game and not have Mullen you'll
be like but what about this amazing
thing that we could do that doesn't that
that is not what you sounds like by the
way wasn't malan's involvement in like
Fable 3 kind of not that that huge
though he he didn't have much a hand on
Fable 3 he yeah so I'm I'm just saying
that I don't know that just removing
malanu is like the answer to Fable yeah
that's yeah maybe so I I would say the
guys at Lin head that they're super
talented people and I think they got a
point to prove so I mean I think I don't
think Legends I would like to just
publicly I would like to apologize to
pet you for what I just said Thank youor
you my bad all right we are just about 5
minutes away from the start of the
Microsoft press conference and we
haven't talked about third party
developers at all so we're going to run
through it uh the big one we're going to
see of course timed exclusive console
situation rise of the Tomb Raider yep
yeah that will definitely be there very
excited for that uh definitely hoping to
uh see the way that that's going to
differentiate itself from Tomb Raider so
I loved that reboot I thought it was
fantastic but you know are they going to
go are is it going to be more tomb
focused C kind it does seem like it just
from the from the teaser here like you
you like Suddenly It's like oh tomb
rating there's tomb rating in Tomb
Raider and there's the voice over where
she's like discovering secrets and that
kind of thing so it's that gets excited
yeah they're definitely lining her up
for Tomb Raider to be a tomb raing game
and then in terms of other third party
stuff this is where we get into the
question of what kind of uh exclusives
can they sort of win in the battle
versus Sony 4 like map packs coming
first or any like are they going to get
called Black Ops 3 Call of Duty content
coming first to Xbox One well there have
been whispers about the Black Ops going
to Sony Call of Duty unconfirmed
unverified unconfirmed unverified yeah
um but apparently that's the thing
that's happening they're finally letting
that go to Sony which means they should
have something else to replace it with
they should have more than something
else to replace it I mean if you look at
the last five years Microsoft has been
fantastic at getting DLC first at
getting exclusive content exclusive
features they've been doing that years
year in year out for the past 5 years
they've been doing a fantastic job at it
and if they've lost Call of Duty and if
they have nothing else to show for it
it'll be a disaster for them yeah I'm
going to call something else right now
let's hear it look at this shirt I'm
just saying this might be a million to
one half life three confirm say those
words yeah yeah so this might be you
know I can always hope right yeah I mean
it's a trolling shirt obviously half 3
is not confirmed by any by any stretch
but I but I'm wearing it now because if
it is is I will be a God that's true
breaking news Half Life free just been
confirmed oh
sh don't do that man I'm sorry well
here's my prediction Kevin we had did
see uh XCOM 2 announced just two weeks
ago and announced for the PC only now no
news about console but of course XCOM
Enemy Unknown and the Enemy Within did
very well on consoles found a great
audience there controller fit very well
it's got to be coming to consoles I
think this is the this is the week we
find out which console and I think given
the Windows 10 integration I think Xbox
is going to get a times console
exclusive for xcon yeah makes sense
that's a good that's a good call I like
that yeah I like it yes I hope that
happens yeah here's another one to
speculate on Battlefront uh that's
another one where Microsoft could make a
bid to get some exclusivity in terms of
maps uh sort of Steal Away a little bit
of that sort of attention but well you
know it's an online focused game EA has
a fantastic relationship with Microsoft
um I think it's entirely feasible that
they get something there mhm if they do
I mean it's it's on the E3 floor and
it's got a lot of Sony branding on it
which tent out front with W is that is
that true that is true if they have Call
of Duty and Battlefront is that is they
got a vice is EA's like Early Access
program thing uh available on Sony's
console it's Microsoft only right it's
Xbox only yeah I mean they I mean
they're in bed with Microsoft already so
here's the one thing to be optimistic
about if you ask me there there are
three major games that have been delayed
for games to come scale bound M Quantum
break and the third one which you can't
remember I just remembered it last
minute thank God got it saved it
yeah if if they're moving those three
big titles and they are big titles if
they're moving those to Gamescom then
they must have a pretty impressive slate
to show us today so I'm really excited
about today's show yep same they would
seem to be confident yeah cuz those are
big ones that uh we saw a bunch of or
certainly two of them revealed last year
and then not going to see until games
come hopefully something will come out
of it uh all right uh we are sort of in
the realm of we might have to go to the
press conference when the feed starts at
any time but we're going to spend our
time talking about more third party
possibilities because of course with all
this Battlefront talk there is the EA
press conference later today so games
like Battlefront games like Mass effects
games like Need for Speed which you know
are they going to maybe only show up
exclusively in the EA show if I had to
bet I'd reckon they be a trailer for
Need for Speed on Xbox it seems that
demographic crosses over um get some
little John and the East Side
boys even if you're putting it up
against Forza 6 though cuz we're
definitely going to see that one today
oh yeah that's true I mean at that's
true they wouldn't they wouldn't uh
cannibalize would they the racing hype I
mean they're two very different type of
racing games right one's a you've got
one press conference you're not going to
show two racing games yeah but one of
them doesn't have Little John and E side
boys I just really want Little John and
E side Market differ I'm going to say
that if that that there's no reason they
shouldn't I mean if one is a you know if
one is a simulation and one is a is a
super fun you know kind of arcade racer
no reason that you wouldn't show both
yeah I agree with Kevin car porn always
does well I guess uh so then uh We've
also got like metal gear solid
five potential pop up in any kind of
Microsoft it's been quite closely
aligned with Sony hasn't it thus far mhm
I would say so yeah I did hear I mean
this wasn't confirmed but I I did hear a
rumor that s Hills was originally going
to be before everything happened for1
trillion was it yeah no sent Hills was
originally going to be a PlayStation 4
exclusive okay that's what the idea was
at least so I think I think Konami and
Sony have a have a close relationship
I'd be amazed if Microsoft managed to
get some exclus there was that story
floating around about Microsoft jumping
in and buying it for an absurd amount of
money oh really which yeah which Phil
Spencer did actually say is not true but
you know Executives have been known to
all right it looks like actually the
press conference is starting right now
we're getting a trailer starting so
let's switch over to that right now and
check it
out and those who make the Great Leap
Forward those who stay as they
are and those that become more than they
ever thought
possible they
discover
explore
compete and are
fearless there are those Satisfied by
Common
Pursuits and those For Whom the
extraordinary will never be
enough so ask
yourself will you
step or will you
[Music]
leave
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this is the Xbox E3
2015 briefing please welcome from 343
Industries Bonnie
Ross thank
you on behalf of everyone here at Xbox
it is Anon honor to welcome you to E3
2015 and to continue the tradition of
what this show has always been about the
characters the games and the stories
that people love in
2015 we are delivering the greatest
games lineup in Xbox history a lineup
that includes new and Innovative IP
groundbreaking Indie Games Blockbuster
franchises and and of course the best
exclusive games launching this
[Music]
year so let's start today with the first
Halo
game thank you that's
right that's where I want to hear the
Applause built from the ground up for
Xbox One and the game that fulfills both
the promise of the Halo Universe and the
power of Xbox
One Master Chief hero or Trader Spartan
lock Friends or
Foe epic worlds epic battles epic scale
this is Halo 5
Guardians XBox One
exclusive not just another Target you
know
every Target is just another Target
Buck 0631 this morning Master Chief was
declared absent without
leave I'm a Spartan now sir I know who
you are yet now you hunt another Spartan
the greatest of your
clan every other Spartan every Soldier
when they hear about this they're going
to hate us you know that
right you're not the only one here
because of
him sonon the covenant's final strong
hole that is where you'll find the
Master Chief and the guardian he
[Music]
seeks let's move bail keep an ear on CS
affirmative Buck denaka defensive
positions I will never bow to
infidels lock we sure the Chief came
this way let's see activating the
emis got to read it Bale do you see this
too let me take a
look Chiefs assault rifle no ammo then
the Master Chief's been through here
which means he has a head start on the
guardian let's get
moving I regret
[Music]
everything looks like ARB is running the
Covenant out of town he've been fighting
for this moment a long time Bale the
covenant's finally
breaking
there's the guardian you think the
chief's already on
board watch
out keep your head down and
run
I'm okay keep going go go Bo AR
[Applause]
you made
it yeah safe and sound inside a
crumbling building better than the
bottom of the
ocean
did you see that you think it's
prometheum
[Applause]
incoming
on I'm
down fck light it up you got
it B on down Tanaka help baale
on it on your feet
Spartan
[Music]
solders weapon cach up there bail Tanaka
flank left fck head up with
me
CL the
Caster don't human
sent you will
something
Soldier Captain's on Deck take them
down I am the warden Eternal Keeper of
the domain in Earth Secrets take him
out
the master chief is called but you your
passage is
denied
we need to get
[Music]
airborne we are airborne and for Runner
Face
[Applause]
Off please welcome from 343 IND
Industries Josh
Holmes this is the biggest and most
ambitious Halo campaign yet built for
seamless drop in Dropout cooperative
play you'll control two distinct Spartan
squads one led by the master chief the
other by Spartan lock now for the first
time the Epic scale of Halo's campaign
carries over to our multiplayer
experience with 24 players AI controlled
adversaries and massive environments
that are four times the size of any
previous Halo map what you're about to
see is a giant leap for Halo multiplayer
and it's playable here at
E3 This Is War
Zone Spartans the broken through our
defenses and our base is in lockdown
eliminate them to secure our home base
let's go Spartans let's put them down
once and for all Spartans are here we
got
this get fire on my
target keep it lock down
sparton
XBox One exclusive World
premiere
[Music]
come on
buddy
what is
[Music]
it
no
welcome back
[Music]
buddy
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the head of Xbox
Bill
Spencer thank
you good morning and welcome investing
in and shipping new exclusive franchises
is critical to our platform success
we're proud to partner with in aunan
Mark Pacini and the teams at comcept and
armateur Studios to create recore an
exclusive new first party franchise for
Xbox
One at Xbox our mission is simple to put
you the gamers at the center of
everything we do to build the best
platform and most reliable service for
both Gamers and developers and to enable
teams to push the boundaries of
creativity technical Innovation and of
course fun today you will see how we're
continuing to invest and innovate for
gamers across our platform our service
our devices and of course our games
anchored by first party exclusives we'll
see a lineup of games from creators
developers and Publishers of all sizes
that show the breadth depth and
diversity of the games you will get to
play on Xbox these games make up what I
believe is the greatest games lineup in
Xbox
history since the launch of Xbox one
we've listened to you the community of
Xbox Gamers and we're grateful for your
continued feedback we continue to
deliver monthly platform feature updates
that enhance your gaming experience and
your response to the updates continues
to motivate us last year the team
decided to tackle a feature that has
been consistently at the top of your
request list and while we weren't sure
it was possible today I'm pleased to
announce Xbox One backward
compatibility your Xbox 360
games the games you've invested your
time and money in and the games you want
to continue to be play will be playable
natively on your Xbox
One our goal is to deliver the largest
games catalog ever on Xbox and Xbox One
backward compatibility allows us to do
just that please welcome Mike iara head
of our platform engineering team to show
us Xbox One backward compatibility and
action
Mike thanks
Phil we'll have over 100 titles this
holiday with hundreds more added in the
months to come digital Xbox 360 titles
will start showing up automatically in
your game library on Xbox
One and Retail disc will work as well
put your disc in download the game and
you're ready to
go let's take a look with one of my
favorite Xbox 360 games this is Mass
Effect on Xbox
One
the game runs exactly like it does on
Xbox 360 but better thanks to the power
of Xbox Live Xbox take a
screenshot you'll get to play
multiplayer with your friends on Xbox
360 and you'll get to take advantage of
Xbox One features like screenshots
broadcasting game DVR and game streaming
with the Xbox app on Windows
10 we've made this easy for game
developers too they just need to approve
title showing up no work is required on
their part to make all of this
possible an initial set of Backward
Compatible titles are available today
for Xbox preview members it will be
available for everyone this
holiday
with Xbox One backward compatibility we
won't charge you to play the games you
already
own thanks and I'll see you on Xbox
Live thanks
Mike now how you play is as important as
what you play We're incredibly proud of
our Xbox One controller but whether
you're a console gamer a PC Gamer or
both we know many of you want more more
customization more precision and more
control in your gaming experience let me
introduce you to the Xbox Elite wireless
controller coming this
[Music]
fall
yeah
[Music]
w
please welcome game director Bethesda
game studios Todd
Howard thank you so much it is great to
be back here and even better to see so
many familiar faces we had an amazing
experience on Xbox 360 doing Oblivion
Fallout 3 Skyrim and we're excited to
finally bring what's special about our
games to Xbox One we like to build the
biggest craziest game worlds we can and
when that world is Fallout there's
nothing else is fun to build in Fallout
4 you experience the events of a nuclear
war forced to abandon your home you take
shelter in an underground Vault events
transpire and you emerge 200 years later
the sole survivor of Vault
111 this is an enormous Dynamic world
where you can create any kind of
character you want go wherever you want
and do whatever you want player freedom
is our number one
goal this is my character
Phil um here on your pit boy you can see
all of my appropriate stats uh my items
and such and we really want to make this
come to life so much so we've even built
a second screen experience that mimics
the pit boy on your smartphone it works
amazing this is running on a Next
Generation version of our creation
engine features full physical based
rendering as well as Dynamic volumetric
[Music]
lighting and then you return home to
find the family robot still waiting as I
live and
breathe it's it's really
you codsworth you're you're still
here so other people could still be
alive too it's worse than I
thought you're suffering from Hunger
induced paranoia perhaps I can whip you
up a snack you must be
famished what food
yeah sure I I need a minute to think
then I'll be right
back after returning to your
neighborhood you then start exploring
this world there are many people you can
meet as well as faithful
companions hey boy what are you doing
out here all by
yourself you want to come with me
pal okay then let's stick together it
does feature first person combat as well
as our bat
system hey you you see that laser musket
on the ground grab it and head inside
I've got a group trapped in here this
laser musket is one of our signature
weapons in the game you crank it and
then Let it Loose
man I don't know who you are but your
time is
impeccable Preston Garvey as you can see
we're in a bit of a mess here a month
ago there were 20 of us yesterday there
were
eight now we're five
I'll help if I can well we do have one
idea
[Music]
that
from here you'll explore the most
ambitious game world that we have ever
[Music]
created
welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
home thank you like I said it's great to
be back here working with the amazing
Folks at Microsoft many of whom we've
worked with for 15 years going back to
mowind on the original
Xbox yeah and you know what we would not
be here really without the support they
gave us then and the support they give
us now but I have bugged them for the
last 15 years for one feature I've
wanted um and working together it's
finally happening as you know modding is
a big part of what we do it is all about
making it your own I'm excited to
announce that mods created on the PC
will be able to be transferred played
and shared for free on Xbox
One thanks again the game's coming out
November 10th we hope you love it
thanks please welcome the Chief
Operating Officer of Electronic Arts
Peter
[Applause]
Moore good morning always great to be
here on the Xbox stage kicking off E3
with my friends and partners from
Microsoft and such exciting news from
Phil that we'll be able to bring some
favorite EA titles from the Xbox 360
platform to players on Xbox One via
backward compatibility now that's going
to be a lot of fun now as you know in
the last year we built a great new
service in EA access on Xbox One it
helps you do three simple things play
first play more and play for less it's
the best of EA for five bucks a month
only on Xbox one I know a lot of you out
there are excited to play our next big
title Madden NFL 16 when it launches on
August the
25th go
Madden but with EA access you'll be the
first to play starting on August the
20th the same goes for Need for Speed
and all of our other upcoming titles
with EA access you're going to get to
play EA's newest releases before any
anyone else members also have unlimited
exclusive access to the Vault the
constantly growing collection of EA's
biggest and best games for Xbox One all
of these titles you see behind me are
ready to download and play as much as
you want whenever you want and it's
about to get even better because this
week we're dropping a Titan on
it Titanfall is joining the EA access
Vault this
week we'll start the summer yep we'll
start the summer with Titanfall and then
you can end it in the world of thetas
because later this summer we're bringing
the Epic Dragon Age Inquisition to the
EA access Vault on Xbox one now let's
not forget EA access members also get
10% off in the Xbox store on full game
downloads like Fifa 16 in-game content
like f FIFA Ultimate Team pack Max or
the latest expansion in Battlefield for
all of you out there that would love to
play first play more and play For Less
come give EA access a try in fact we're
going to help you out with that this
week in celebration of e3 we're opening
up the EA access Vault to all Xbox Live
go members that's right all 12 titles
just download the E access app on your
Xbox One and play as much as you want
for free all week
long now before I go I've got some news
that I think you're really going to like
because of your passion for the insanely
fun Plants versus Zombies
franchise I'm excited to announce today
Plants versus Zombies Garden Warfare
[Music]
this will be the funniest craziest most
over-the-top shooter experience you've
ever played we're tapping into the heart
of what fans loved about the original
and adding new characters new worlds to
explore brand new ways to play and tons
more Plants Vs zombies Garden Warfare 2
arrives next spring and here is the
exclusive World premier trailer thanks
everyone and have a great
E3 world
[Applause]
Premiere since the dawn of time plants
have protected Suburbia from the
zombies but now the world has
changed welcome to Z
Baria
that
got
[Music]
tlight
Wings the shov
the
[Music]
the Ford Motor Company was born on the
racetrack it's a racing Legacy that
propelled the company into
1966 when Henry Ford II the GT40 and an
international super team stunned the
racing World by finishing 1 23 at the 24
hours of Lon
in the following years the GT not only
went on to defend its championship in
the race of the century it dominated the
decade becoming a legend in Motor Sports
the crowd cheers the champagne bottles
pop
now on its 50th
Anniversary the GT is back and its
racing Legacy lives
up developed in a secret Studio beneath
Ford's engineering center GT's rebirth
has
[Music]
begun stunning the world the 2015
Detroit Auto
Show and in 2016 set to return and
reclaim its place amongst the legends of
Lon this is what we've been racing
cool
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen from Ford Motor
Company Henry Ford III and from turn 10
Studios Dan
greenawalt thank you Xbox is the home of
racing Forza has built a reputation for
Innovation quality and dedication to its
fans partnering with Forza allows us to
bring the Ford GT to everyone thanks
Henry for and Motorsports 6 is the most
beautiful the most technically Advanced
and the biggest game we've ever built
let's take a
look XBox One
[Music]
exclusive
oh
beautiful it
[Music]
is start a
reu how
beautiful it
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
World
premiere
[Music]
oh
GL
[Applause]
[Music]
we were always told in might come to
this that one
day everything we ever knew could
[Music]
end
C it was a weaponized
virus one by one we began to
fall people started tearing each other
apart until society as we knew it
collapsed there's
[Music]
anary
it was a
signal that the normal lives we
LED we're
gone we are activated as a last
resort we are the
division we don't know how many of us
there
are or what it will take to save what
remains but there is one thing we do
[Music]
know there cannot be any hope for
tomorrow if we don't fight for
today
[Applause]
orary please welcome president Ubisoft
Americas lauron
theour what you just saw is footage from
our next chapter in the Tom clany family
the division is a deep realistic action
RPG that feels
personal this is New York you belong in
that world you recognize it you could be
there assuming of course that uh you're
a secretly trained agent which video
games will make possible for
you our ter Clancy games and Xbox have a
shared DNA since the original ghost Tron
shipped on the very first day of the
Xbox Live
service since then life players have
been among our most passionate fans
that's why I am pleased to announce that
Xbox One players will be the first ones
to try the division via an exclusive
beta this
[Applause]
December now if you're an Xbox clany fan
I have more on October 13 we launch
Rainbow Six Siege the next installment
in the rainbow
franchise think simple fun gaming routs
blessed with nextg
technology most players love it for the
intensity for me it's the destructible
environments that really hit the
spot when Siege comes out fans of the
series will also be able to play the
full versions of award-winning Rainbow 6
Vegas and Vegas 2 thanks to the backward
compatibility on Xbox
one better
yet better yet those two games will come
free with Rainbow Six
Siege
so until then let's take a look at this
groundbreaking game thank
[Applause]
you
okay they're setting up in the
plane drone's up looks like bombs in the
back on the right yeah that's it all
right let's go Rick you chain go up top
like you did last time right behind
you going
right they're locking it down I see him
yep two barricades on the left
ready go go man use a sledge go got him
right there right there he's right on
you thr
smoke let's
go got him got him Hold the Wall
planting
charge take him out he's right at the
door bomb's in there I'm on it can you T
3 seconds only 2 seconds I got it I got
it all right man let's go wait for
itom they're flanking us I'm
down right behind in that wall keep
moving guys I see him yeah nice
[Applause]
[Music]
shot Windows 10 and XBox One
exclusive
[Music]
he
come with
[Music]
me a brawl is surely
Brewing you're
up and me we
got what we know it's time to throw away
the
[Music]
the me let
go
[Music]
oh baby time
to
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome the director of ID at
Xbox Chris
Charlo hey everybody what you just saw
was a sampling of the titles coming from
the more than 1,000 independent
developers making Xbox One and windows
games part of the Ide at Xbox program
you know enabling creators to realize
their visions and deliver incredible new
experiences to Xbox players around the
world is what the ID at Xbox program is
all about and it's been awesome to see
the level of critical and Commercial
Success developers have already had on
Xbox and we're really just at the start
now I'd like to introduce you to some
amazing creators whose games are going
to be debuting exclusively on Xbox
One hi I'm Steve ganner from Fulbright
when we created gone home we wanted to
tell a very small personal story so we
created a game that took place entirely
in one family's house but with our next
game Tacoma we wanted to push ourselves
to explore new ideas and New
Frontiers what is life like in a place
that's completely unfamiliar to you and
me a place that's beyond the bounds of
Earth and what has happened to the crew
of lunar Transfer Station
Tacoma
[Music]
control come
in
control
[Music]
hello Odin where is the crew that
information has been
[Music]
classified
Odin what am I going to find behind this
door hi I'm Derek Bradley from Aurora 44
our small team in New Zealand has set
out to create a harsh open world to
explore one where it's up to you to
determine who is friend and who is foe
in a place where player-to-player
relationships are key to survival but
who to trust who to fight and who to run
away from are all decisions you must
make for
yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone I'm sherida from tiger and
Squid Beyond eyes is the story of Ray a
young girl who for the first time in her
life has to leave the safety of her
childhood home and go explore the
outside world but being blind Ray has to
visualize the world through other senses
such as hearing touch and smell I made
Beyond eyes because I wanted to share
with the world a story of Hope if we
embrace the challenges that life throws
at us and if we open ourselves up to new
experiences it can be a beautiful
world
[Music]
hi I'm Chad from studio mdhr and this is
my brother Jared a few years ago when we
first sat down to sketch cuphead we had
no idea that character would eventually
be the star of his own Xbox game at that
point the only thing we were certain of
is that we wanted our game to have the
look of a 1930s cartoon and the
Precision of a classic 16-bit platformer
with the help of Microsoft we have
brought our sketch to life today we are
excited to give everyone a quick peek
into the world of
[Music]
cuphead
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
that's rad um those last four titles
really show the breadth of experiences
the independent developers are bringing
to Xbox one today and we'd like to
really thank those creators for joining
us on stage and sharing a Peak at the
experiences they'll be bringing to Xbox
One in Windows
10 now I'd like to talk about a new
pilot program we're launching for
independent developers called Xbox game
preview game preview is a new type of
offering that lets Gamers buy and play a
selection of games while they're still
an active development it enables the
community to get involved and even help
shape the final outcome with their
feedback so this type of Early Access
gaming is already popular on PC and
we're excited to offer it to our players
but we want to make sure it comes to
console in a way that makes sense so
every game in the program has a free
trial so you can play it and then make
an educated decision on whether you want
to jump in early or wait and see how
development
progresses we'll be launching a select
number of games into the Xbox game
preview over the next year including the
following titles The Long Dark by
Hinterlands sheltered from unic Cube
Elite dangerous from Frontier and Daisy
from Bohemia
interactive pretty
cool if you'd like to join the Xbox game
preview community and get involved you
can do it starting today later this
afternoon the long dark and Elite
dangerous will be available for download
on your Xbox one please give them a try
can't wait to hear what you
think now before I go I'd like to
welcome to the stage one of the true
Visionaries of Early Access game
development to talk about his new IP
which is going to be launching
exclusively on PC and Xbox One please
welcome the creator of DayZ Dean
Hall I want a game that is not a game I
want a game that is a universe a
universe built not on scripts or quests
but on the the laws of physics biology
and chemistry a simulation MMO that
explores Mankind's expansion into
space the chance to be a Pioneer in a
harsh Universe swamped with the risk of
death yet peppered with the Havens of
Fortune for the past year I have been
working with the technology company
improbable to turn my long-term
prototype and to a
reality it
worked We Are The Architects of this new
universe but you the players through
Xbox One game preview and PC will govern
its
Destiny you been wrench not again every
day
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen from Crystal
Dynamics game director Ryan
Horton I'm thrilled to be here today on
behalf of the entire team at Crystal
Dynamics to demo the world premiere
gamep playay of Rise of the Tomb
Raider XBox exclusive holiday
wait till you see this
[Music]
[Applause]
via I guess if I was going to hide a
lost
city this might be the kind of God
forsaken place I'd do
it Storm's getting closer we have a
couple hours at most should be enough
time we're almost to the
top what do you
think we're close to something Jonah I
can feel it just this last stretch to
the
top all right
let's see what's up
[Music]
there looks like we climb from here keep
your eyes open from falling ice right
you ready let's do
it there's lot of loose eyes up here
let's take it slow and steady just stay
with me
look out hold
on I'm going to dig in can you make it
across I can make
it holy I don't think I can make
that jump stay there I'll for a line you
at the
top almost there Lara you got
it
[Music]
Jonah we made it I see the
ruin oh
God
I got you I got you Laura can you
hear me
yeah I'm going to pull you back
up
there over
there quick swing me to the other side
okay here it
goes
laa I can't hold you the RO flipping cl
cl oh Mo godamn
it go back shoulder get the shter
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
go
[Music]
something else dwells in the darkness of
this place but I've got to
[Music]
continue I finally feel a sense of
purpose
again like I'm doing what I was meant to
do some kind of
[Applause]
marker the journey will be
perilous but I must find a
[Applause]
[Music]
way
incredible this is
[Music]
it
[Applause]
[Music]
XBox One
exclusive you never forget your first
game and the more of them you play the
more of them you love every memory is a
story to cherish and share we fought
back monsters soord across the Stars
achieve the impossible We Were Heroes
there were games that blew us apart and
games that brought us
together whether you're reliving
childhood memories or discovering
Classics for the first time you'll see
why the best stories will never be
forgotten through the hard times and the
good I have to celebrate you
baby I have to praise you like I
should I have to praise
you I have to praise
you
I have to PR you
like I have to PR
you please welcome Studio head R Craig
[Music]
[Applause]
Duncan 2015 marks the 30th annivers of
rare and we wanted to celebrate by
giving rare fans an iconic collection of
rare
games love man one of the things that
rare has done consistently over three
decades is evolve as a studio rare has
redefined genres with its own special
formula and we're ready to do that again
today I'm proud to give you a first look
at a new exclusive game from rare
a game that will allow our players to
have unique and memorable adventures
together a shared World adventure game
set in a Fantastical world this game
will bring players together and give
them the freedom to play with Limitless
possibilities this is by far the most
ambitious game rare has ever
created XBox One exclusive World
premiere
[Music]
[Applause]
m
[Music]
[Applause]
on
[Music]
[Applause]
Xbox One and Windows 10
exclusive let me tell you a
story of a world of great
Beauty full of
promise
full of
magic and lately full of
[Music]
adventurers eager to
explore eager to tell a story of their
[Music]
own but this is not a story of
Heroes they are
Intruders in a land that does not want
them such is the nature of
Heroes hungry for what they don't have
obsessed with their
Legends but this is not their
story and I will end their little fairy
[Applause]
[Music]
tale joining us from Microsoft Studios
kudo
tunod
games like Fable Legends show our
commitment to putting fans and Gamers at
the center of everything we do Legends
is free to play on both Xbox One and
Windows 10 PCS this means Fable fans
running Windows 10 will be able to play
with their fellow Gamers on Xbox One
anything you earn or buy on one version
of the game becomes part of the
experience on the other and if you love
gaming more is coming Windows allows
developers to push the boundaries of
creativity to deliver Gamers experiences
they will love from console gaming to PC
gaming even virtual reality
gaming today we are proud to announce a
new relationship with Val
[Applause]
VR we'll be working closely with valve
to make Windows 10 the best platform for
VR Gaming and last week we were on the
Oculus stage announcing a partnership
with Oculus the Xbox One controller will
be included with every oculus rift at
launch this puts our high Precision
gaming controller at the center of VR
Gaming and Xbox One games will be
playable on Oculus Rift by streaming
Xbox One games to Rift through Windows
10 gamers can play the games they love
on the newest
devices Microsoft's also pioneering a
new era of holographic Computing an era
of mixed reality the ability to bring
Holograms into your real world in
January we unveiled Microsoft holens the
world's first untethered holographic
computer powered by Windows
10 Holograms mixed with your real world
unlocks all new experiences freed from
the boundaries of your
screens so far we have shown new ways
for people to create to communicate to
work and to learn today we are very
excited to show you how Microsoft
hollowland can change the world of
[Applause]
gaming to show you how it works let me
introduce brand director at moyang Lydia
Winters Lydia thanks
[Applause]
Cuda 4 years ago at E3 I met the moyang
team for the very first time soon after
I joined them on this unbelievable
Adventure this game has changed millions
of lives including my own in the past 5
years we've been blown away by the
amount of people who have been playing
our game the community's incredible
creativity has taken Minecraft into
places we never could have
imagined every day we see new and
exciting things being made on July 4th
and 5th in London we are going to have
the biggest Minecraft celebration in the
world at Minecon
2015 we can't wait to share more with
the community there and be inspired by
their
ideas we're always trying to harness new
technology and create new ways of
playing the game with that in mind
please let me welcome sax Pian from
Microsoft Studios and we're excited to
be able to show a new version of
Minecraft built specifically for
Microsoft Hol
lens thank you
lyan to show our demo today we're using
a special camera this display technique
is like putting a hollow lens right on
the camera itself allowing the entire
audience to see the Holograms now this
is a live demo with real working code
let's show what it can do
you can play the Minecraft you know
today on Hollow lens saak grabbed his
Xbox controller to play through a giant
holographic portal into a 3D Minecraft
world right on the wall even though I
don't have a hollow lens I'm able to
play together with Sachs from my
Surface are you going to come join my
game Lydia I'm in
now I see you jumping around
one of the cool things about Holland is
that it lets you display Minecraft
virtually anywhere you can get different
perspectives on your Minecraft world
it's awesome to play with the controller
but could we show them something new
saxs sure just take our experiment off
the wall and then put it on the table
over
here create
[Music]
world
[Applause]
I see Lydia way up
there as I run around and play saxs can
easily navigate and manip manipulate the
world using his voice and His Hands he
can walk around the Hologram pan around
for different viewpoints and even look
inside
let's follow Lydia around for a bit
follow
player I can zoom in in out for a better
perspective
closer all the way in close
up what are you up to liia I'm hopping
in a mine
cart do let's take a ride down to the
Village we're going to pick a different
perspective
[Music]
overview
it's incredibly cool to have Minecraft
on your table imagine seeing your own
worlds like
this isn't it crazy that I see sax just
standing at the table but through the
hollow lens he can see a whole Minecraft
Universe at his
fingertips you can even raise the entire
world and see things that are normally
hidden way underneath the ground could
you give us a sneak peek of what's under
that Village saxs sure grab the world
lift it up and let's see what's hiding
underneath
Lydia ooh huge stronghold right
underneath I'm going to mark that for
you mark
that well you're going to have to find a
way to break in I see it I'm on my way
there
now I'm placing some so I can blow my
way into this stronghold I I could use a
light though
saxs good
strategy using Hollow lens I have access
to all console commands in Minecraft
just using my voice but um I can just
focus my Gaze on the TNT and say
lightning
strike step
back who there's a lot of materials down
there I wouldn't have seen without you
there's one more thing I want to do with
lightning see a pig pen over here I
think the pigs need an upgrade do it
lightning
strike there you have it zombie
[Applause]
Pikman from playing Minecraft on your
wall to an entire world right on your
table Microsoft Hollow lens gives the
community a different way to play in the
worlds they already love we will have
even more Minecraft news to share at
MineCon in a few weeks thank
you ladies and gentlemen Gears of War
co-creator Rod
Ferguson 10 years ago Gears of War
debuted here at the Xbox E3 briefing and
this year we're taking you back to where
it all began today I'm happy to announce
Gears of War Ultimate Edition the
original Gears of War completely
remastered and modernized for Xbox One
and coming August 25th it's the first at
its best fully rebuilt in 1080P loaded
with new content and 60 frames per
second in
multiplayer and you can play that
multiplayer early in our onewe P public
beta that starts
today so tune in to the Xbox daily live
from E3 this afternoon to learn
more oh yeah and one more thing I I want
to give you a taste of something else
we're working at at the
Coalition thank
you XBox One exclusive World
premiere
[Music]
looks like it went this way come on
hey wind's picking up no need to worry
just yet and watch it that thing could
be
anywhere
[Music]
hey there's water
here sure that's
safe it's just rain water yeah with
stuff floating in it let's assume I'll
live
tell me you heard that there it's on the
move after
it wind flare incoming get inside the
for
come on seriously damn it back to
to or not jie yeah there's a gate here
coming go
don't stop keep going hey there's
shelter just
ahead
holy JD door go get
inside now what now we find out if that
thing's in here with
us
what is this I don't know let's go check
it out um it's
[Music]
glowing you
here what is that don't touch
it J I'm
okay son of a I think it shorted out my
flashlight great well you're glowing now
so that's good let's just get the hell
out of
here there it is Qui come
on it's on the roof go
move oh no all right just don't touch
the
pods it's above
us
easy
I'm beginning to think we're not the
hunters anymore let's just clear this
Courtyard there come on through the door
yeah
going
the
okay you're a big fella easy
know oh that's not
[Music]
good jie could you some help
here
[Music]
behind
you
please welcome back Bill
Spencer it's great to have Gears of War
back on our Xbox stage to see Gears of
War for gameplay running real time on
Xbox One and to see my friend Rod
Ferguson at the
helm today we showed you the greatest
games line up in Xbox history new and
Innovative games that speak to the
boundless creativity from studios around
the world Blockbuster franchises you
know in love trailblazing independent
games from a new wave of creators who
are redefining game development and game
play all anchored by the best exclusives
on any platform Xbox is the only place
where you can play Gears of War Fable
Legends forts of Motorsport 6 rise of
the Tomb Raider and of course Halo 5
Guardians all this year
this lineup is supported by Xbox Live
and our commitment to make your gaming
experience better with an expanded
library of games with backward
compatibility new gaming hardware and
accessories access to great games first
with EA access Next Generation virtual
and mixed reality gaming experience and
access to games and early development
with the game review program there truly
has never been a better time to be an
Xbox gamer if you've been waiting to
move from your Xbox 360 now is the
[Music]
time today we've shared only a fraction
of what's coming to Xbox One and Windows
10 this holiday and next we have more
surprises in store this week on the Xbox
Daily Show including the unveil of a
whole new Xbox One user experience and
more new games coming to Xbox One this
summer we look forward to Bringing
exciting features from Xbox Live and
some of most popular Xbox games and
experiences to Windows 10 when it
launches this July 29th and at Gamescom
in August you'll see the latest from
Quantum break scalebound Crackdown and
new first party game
reveals thank you for joining us this
morning
it's your expectation your dedication
and your passion for games that
motivates and inspires not only me but
every single member of Team Xbox thank
[Applause]
you
[Music]
I got the
feeling
you got to feel it you got to feel it I
got feeling my
soul I got the
feeling you
[Music]
got
[Applause]
[Music]
let
and there you have it folks the
Microsoft press conference here at E3
2015 what a show there was a lot of
stuff that got us all here clamoring in
the War Room uh at Gamespot HQ we are
going to run through all of it so stick
with us here we're going to share our
Impressions our hopes our dreams for the
things that we saw and uh stuff that
really impressed us so guys we're going
to start off right where we thought they
would start off Halo 5 Guardians kicked
off the Microsoft press conference and
they showed some four player co-op camp
campaign play showed some trailers what
you guys think I thought it was
fantastic I thought they did a great job
with Halo 5 I think they they knew that
game needed to be different enough and I
think they they emphasized what was
going to be new about this game I think
with the war zone multiplayer at the end
that they showed I think that's going to
be really interesting I think the cynic
and people are going to say okay they're
adding a bit of Titanfall in there
they're adding a bit of Destiny in there
but personally I think they've done a
really good job I think it's it's
looking way more distinct than previous
Halo games there was always like a a
common like thread between each of them
whereas this feels like 343 kind of
ripping it away from Bungie and making
it of its own Halo 4 was a small step
towards that but it still was very much
tied into the old thing but by pushing
Master Chief onto the other side and
having a brand new group of people to
kind of look after it's really really
interesting I like that I mean we were
reading about the four player co-op
stuff um beforehand but I like that we
got to see that in action and it looked
really cool where um lock was giving
orders to different people and they were
kind of doing as he was told as they
were told it looked really really cool
I'm excited about it it still feels like
Halo though because you got I mean even
that that grunt spot was the perfect
Halo spot for me I regret everything
exactly was adorable it's it's still got
that I don't know that that little bit
of edge to me like that little bit of
humor that and plus lots of purple
purple a Halo color purple and yellow so
it's both old Halo and new Halo the
contrast yeah I really do like that four
player co-op Dynamic there were showing
off the banter reminded me of ODST of
reach and those are some of uh Bungie's
more uh person ality driven Halos and so
I'm definitely looking forward to those
characters being flushed out uh the new
Promethean uh sort of hunter hunter
killer is that the Terminator reference
there uh so some new Promethean enemies
on display here as well as the Spartan
abilities from the multiplayer beta yeah
like we just saw there there's a lot
more cooperation between characters like
you we saw the uh one of the Spartans
Reviving another one which is something
new to the series and it is like um it's
it's very similar to stuff like gears
and other Co-op based games like I think
and when you're playing on your own you
can issue a command to one of the AI
characters to go and do it whereas
whether you're playing with an actual
human you can go over and do it yourself
so yeah and there's a bit towards the
end where the actual uh the main boss
enemy that came up comes up at the
ground and it looks just like Destiny so
it's like it felt like a destiny moment
there I was like wow yeah they they are
kind of drawing from all of its all The
Inspirations and where like where where
the Halo has G gone on to become what
it's become the different games they
they taken everything so yeah it's it's
looking very very cool I like I like the
look of it so far I'm excited for Halo
once again after a somewhat tepid
response to Halo 4 and Halo 5 Guardians
do out this fall uh they announced the
release date is it an October release
date iing on it currently yeah I think
that was right I'm going to I was just
so hyped by I didn't I was just falling
off my chair October 27th Halo 5
Guardians all right next up we have uh
they showed us their classic their
pillar of the of the the sort of old IPS
M next up we have a new IP recor what
did you guys think I thought it looked
fantastic um I it reminded me of IO in
certain moments you know that that
isolation you against the world I really
like this idea that uh your companion in
this we thought it was going to be a dog
cuz most games have dogs these days
right and it was a dog for most of the
trailer yeah yeah but it was actually an
orb right it would it's a soul a digital
soul that you can put into different uh
machines I thought it was a really cool
idea
um I think the the development Talent
behind this is fantastic and I think
it's got a lot of Promise the
development Talent being kg inafune and
the creators of Metroid Prime yeah so
that's armateur Studios which is the uh
the kind of some of the developers that
um from Metro Prime retro who recently
made a Batman Arkham Origins Blackgate
for uh uh VA and PS4 and that kind of
stuff and they've also done a lot of
Port work on Metal Gear Solid and a
whole bunch of other games so they have
got a pedigree to them I mean I mean
black gate wasn't a massive success and
it wasn't exactly amazing didn't set the
world on fire they did trade off a lot
of that Metroid Prime Metroid kind of
history but I'm looking forward to
seeing what they do with something a
little more original and it's good to
see in aun working on something else
again can I just ask a whiny question if
you were a backer of uh concept's uh new
platform game what's it called might
number n might number n if you were a
backer of Mighty number n and you know
that inafune is now working on something
else before the before the final
development of that game how would you
feel I don't know I think I I a lot of
people might Bey enough to know that his
his part of Designing might be over by
that point and um but then again he's a
guy that worked at Capcom on a whole
bunch of games at once I mean he had his
fingers in so many pies at Capcom and a
lot of those games came out and they
were excellent so he's a guy that's
clearly um capable of working on
multiple projects at the same time he's
just not done it since he was at Capcom
you know because he's not been at a
studio that big but as concept continues
to grow I reckon he'll start moving back
into that role fair enough maybe I was
being a bit too cynical about that
you you well balanced well balanced uh
right at the end there with recor of
course you saw uh sort of a tease of
some of the other sort of animal-like
shapes that the orb will be able to
inhabit there was a gorilla uh kind of
floating octopus uh Spider creepy uh and
so you know definitely some some
gameplay diversity maybe uh you can
extrapolate from that but recor one of
the big surprises of Microsoft's E3 2015
press conference
looking very cool from recor we uh
headed into the biggest one of the
biggest bombshell quotes of perhaps of
this E3 your Xbox 360 games will be
playable natively on your Xbox One
Megaton Megaton that is huge that is
absolutely huge incredibly infuriating
considering I just put all those games
away I'm so annoyed right
now I think this is a fantastic
initiative by Microsoft it really is
going to win a lot lot of fans over
everyone and and their brother have an
Xbox 360 right everyone has it everyone
has a massive collection of Xbox 360
games my sister's even got an Xbox 3
your sister has an xox you don't even
have a sister everyone has one so uh you
know I think it's a great idea there was
a great dig at Sony because and I think
I got quite a deserved one because
PlayStation Now is streamed games that
we already own like at a price you know
and they said you can play your old
games for free on Xbox One and that was
a big shots fired there that some shots
fired shot fired won't charge you to
play games you already own uh so that of
course raises the question how yeah can
cuz you can't imagine them being like
yep yeah because they say okay you have
your your disc put the disc in download
it to your Xbox One and then you can
play but you can't imagine them just
letting anyone with a game disc use it
cuz then use retail Market becomes a
whole different thing and you could just
pass it around and I don't know it's
that's the kind of uh free license that
platform holders have been really
reluctant to give up uh in this
generation of consoles however they were
also reluctant to talk about any kind of
backwards compatibility and now we're
seeing it implemented so what do you
guys think how's surprising how far
Microsoft's come from trying to lock
down like the uh pre-owned Market to
this point where it seems like they're
just completely open complet revers
feeling that there's going to be some
caveats that they just don't want to dig
into because it would kind of the moment
I think I think going to be open about
this going be think I think I'm going to
be totally cool about this I definitely
think they're going to detail it and
they're going to be open about it but I
think they don't want to go into the
nitty-gritties where one every CD has
every game has a unique code that once
is used is gone like they don't want to
talk about that because the thing is
that they're not going to make any money
on backwards compatibility this is never
going to be about money I mean it
upsells the Xbox One slightly yes but
this is this is about fan service right
this is about their Engineers doing
loads of software emulation on the back
end so we can play our old games this
isn't about so do you reckon everyone
will be able to just pass around the
same game and yeah I think that's going
to be absolutely fine I think a few
Publishers who would re-releasing
digital Deluxe editions going to be a
bit annoyed that the originals are now
going to be available on Xbox One or
they might just not make them available
because they said it's not yeah it's not
going to require any more development to
make the it work but it does require Dev
approval right so it's not just I or
well yeah the game developers or you
know whoever happens to own that license
needs to approve it it's not just let's
put everything out there so it was a bit
like share play where Sony was like oh
this is going to be great you can just
tra you can play games online with your
friends all the time and then every
publisher went no you're not you're not
doing that no yeah uh very really
interesting to see how that's going to
work out uh that's Xbox One backwards
compatibility with the Xbox 360 wow big
huge uh then we've got to look at the
elite controller mhm the Xbox Elite
controller what did you guys think that
I I was writing a new story at the time
so I was kind of looking up and down and
basically every time I looked up the
controller was just like in bits so I'm
not completely sure what's happening
there someone's going to have swappable
Parts you can pop off the Dom analog
stick for the concave one if you want or
uh the d-pad I think was the most sort
of eye-catching it was that uh that like
little Basin that had uh different
angles so it was again it was like a a
little hole to sort of or cave to rest
your thumb in and then move around from
there I'll be really happy if uh either
I have some kind of other bumpers that I
can stick in there or some bumper
alternative because the bumpers are the
thing I hate the most on the Xbox One
controller right I see so I would really
love to get something in there but I
think also something to note was that
they it says compatible with Xbox One
and Windows 10 like it was right there
on the screen kind of uh takes a shine
off Microsoft's not Microsoft's steam's
new controller right if it's kind of got
like it looks like for example that bit
there it looks like almost like a mouse
pad area um so so if it could do if they
could add that kind of functionality
into it it could kind of cross over and
let make it more suited for uh PC play I
am slightly amazed that if you could
make any personally if I could make any
modification to the Xbox One controller
I would add in uh lithium batteries or
like recharge abilities basically but
this appears to be still have the
battery casing still have the battery
casing yeah they're going hard on the
Barry casing it does look I mean there's
going to be a lot of third party you
know peripheral makers out there
creating custom bits and it's a good way
to customize your own controller like I
I don't know you know people love buying
the Halo version of a controller if they
could just release like a Halo you know
dpad or something like that it's it's a
good way to for Microsoft and for
peripheral makers to make more money and
give people a chance to express
themselves through their controller
express yourself don't just put a
sticker on it CU it'll rub off uh also
it's got those tabs on the back have you
guys ever played with a controller with
these things cuz they're definitely in
use in competitive circles you because
it's a way to get more button access
without taking your thumb off the analog
stick to press the buttons uh you know I
don't know have you tried it I've never
tried it I mean the last time I saw
something like that was when Call of
Duty hacking was a big thing and people
were adding in shortcuts in the back
just so they can do weird like 360 no
scopes and that kind of stuff but it was
extra buttons that's why that's how they
could do it tomorrow I knew it I knew I
Wen that bad all this time but yeah um
I've I've never used it but I'm I'm
definitely intrigued like it it opens up
the uh with like uh more strategy games
arriving and that kind of thing it could
open up a lot of possibilities with
shortcuts and that kind of thing
programmable buttons so yeah it's
definitely interesting right on Xbox
Elite controller for Xbox One and
Windows 10 coming
sometime uh then I feel like we entered
a little bit of a lull in the press
conference because we went to that
Fallout 4 demo and don't get me wrong
I'm very excited for Fallout 4 but the
demo at bethesda's press conference last
night was so much more expansive Todd
Howard was so much more animated uh this
just felt like a lesser version so what
was the point yeah he was I'm not quite
sure why this happened yeah I I'm not
yeah I mean they announced the uh The
Fallout 3 coming with Fallout 4 I guess
yeah on Xbox one so I guess well then
they also talked about mods and I think
maybe that's the big story here is that
mods created on the PC can be shared on
Xbox One and I mean you guys have all
seen plenty of mods in your day for
Skyrim for GTA but for Fallout 3
there's some for Fallout 4 the Mind
reels at how many mods you can bring
down the pipe especially given the
customization we saw on display in
Fallout 4 last night during bethesda's
press conf absolutely yeah I'm actually
I should be a bit more positive about
this because I think PC modding uh being
able to be being able to play that on
the Xbox one I think that's going to be
a big deal again I think it strengthens
that that link between the Xbox One and
Windows 10 which Microsoft is showing so
much at the moment and you know what I
think it's a really good move I think
it's it's a pretty big deal for Bethesda
as well like let's not forget yesterday
they announced something similar for
Doom with Bethesda net as well so they
clear yeah snapmap and Bethesda net
which is powering a lot of their online
presence for from forums to actual like
user generated content propagation that
kind of stuff so it's it's it's
interesting I like that just kind of
going back to its PC routs in an in an
element for some of these franchises and
allowing people to come together I think
it's strengthening the community which
is good because a lot of these games
they rely on people generating coming
together like after a while like Fallout
becomes you once you've played Fallout a
bunch of times like it kind of stagnates
and you're kind of like playing the
stuff over and over again but if they're
giving the people to come the
opportunity to come together and keep
keep it fresh it's just it just works
out good for them when they release like
extra content officially cuz people will
be already there I just wonder how far
it goes or who The Gatekeepers are for
some of this because I think of using
something like even even with Skyrim and
using the ne you know the Nexus stuff
and all that stuff like you can easily
just break all over the place and
yeah there's a whole lot that can go
wrong when you do mods so I kind of
wonder who's going to be the gatekeeper
are these things going to need to be
approved is this going to open up the
whole you know paid mods you know can of
worms all over again you know what are
what are they going to do to be keeping
us from you know I I don't know how many
people are prepared to break their copy
of Fallout 4 on a console interesting
it's interesting point yeah that that
point that Kevin made when they tried to
introduce steam mods uh mods for Skyrim
um there was a lot of backlash and
Bethesda said that maybe introducing it
with a community that was was
pre-existing with fall with Skyrim was a
bad idea so this might be an opportunity
to redo that stuff again from the outset
and and make paid mods a thing it is
kind of a start from scratch situation
not just because it's a new game but
because you're also talking about the
console transferability and you know
sort of creating starting to create that
mod Community toor you were talking
about on a console it's going to be
really interesting to see uh how this
works out as we look ahead to the
release of Fallout 4 this November
November 10th yeah and then uh from
there we talk some EA access okay
Titanfall coming to Dragon Age
Inquisition EA access is free to All
Gold members this week which means
nothing to us who are stranded in La
without our consoles uh but I don't know
anything here substantive to you guys EA
access uh I mean Titanfall kind of it
burned bright but didn't burn for very
long right and it was I mean in the last
Microsoft sale I remember it was going
for just a few pounds and dollars and
the DLC was giving away for free fre I
kind of yeah you know what even though
it looks a bit desperate it's actually
really smart move because the main thing
that they need right now is a community
they need a big community of players who
want to keep on playing it keep on
talking about it and I think that's what
they losing and I think that's why
they're giving it away for free now
you're talking about Titanfall
specifically here because we know a new
Titanfall is in the works respawns not3
this year though so we're not going to
be hearing anything about that however
yeah keep keep Titanfall in players
Minds as I remember that yeah I had a
good time really good yeah uh then we
went to uh a game that I was like a game
that I was delighted to see but maybe
drew a few sort of oh Plants versus
Zombies Garden Warfare too anybody any
any I'm not big on that a that's fine I
mean it looked Charming it looked cool
um I I I guess I could go back I want to
go back and play the original why would
you want to do that there's a CLE coming
out at some point it looks cute that was
a fun one it's one of these that like
during a press conference is really
delightful to just see the like
saturated colors and like playfulness uh
which we'll definitely get to later as
we talk about the Indie showcase and uh
of course rares appearance but before we
get there uh judging from our pre-show
I'm guessing that not not a lot of us
have a lot to say about fortza
Motorsport 6 not really it's a racing
game
racing RAC every car has almost all the
time four wheels on every
two doors either side go up and down
like well there was a lot more going up
and down on that car than just every
vehicle that's ever been in Forza like
it was a bit of a weird moment when they
were showing off for 6 because they were
lowering a car into the I was I just
kind of wondering is it going to fall
that's a that's a headline right there
freak accident car you know Ford pays
millions in
Damages I just wish they had Dan
Greenwalt then step out of that car know
like that's get get me a peterm tattoo
level approximation of stunt you know
executive stunt kind of thing but what
do they expect people to do right now go
oh my God oh my God it's a car yeah they
expect you to do the same thing with
this car that you did with the trailer
augle the cars say damn those cars look
good uh cool well the cars are going to
happen later uh but speaking of UGL as
soon as I think the the the first frame
of this trailer came up we all knew what
it was dark souls 3 our first look here
uh
at let's try that again whoops moving
swiftly you guys they show Dark Souls 3
and this is what it looked like right
from the bonfire we see right from the
beginning produced by Bandy Namco in
that text everyone gasped everyone was
excited uh got that sort of bloodborne
dragging a body around do you ever even
drag bodies in that game anyways Dark
Souls 3 not announced in terms of like
exclusivity this or that but this was
our first look at it uh Kevin you are a
something of a fan of the Dark Souls
series what do you say about Dark Souls
3 I'm hyped but I mean what is there to
say right now we have this little teaser
trailer and not a whole and it's giant
Night Rises but not a not a whole lot
beyond that I mean this looks very dark
soul so for me it's going to be a
question of of setting it's going to be
a question of setting it's what it's
going to be in this sort of dark fantasy
world there's your setting I mean
there's a lot of similarities between
the first two dark souls and this I mean
it's got the usual like callbacks you
know it's got the crown a kingdom that's
you know fallen and you know there's
going to be a a kind of struggle or you
know it's always surrounding like power
struggles and what happened to this
Kingdom where is the monarch that kind
of thing and obviously like uh some sort
of demon Scourge or Uprising happening
at the time so yeah it looks it looks
very similar to original dark we haven't
seen a lot of the new stuff obviously
there was that leak earlier which
suggested a lot of crazy things like you
know sacrifices and that kind of stuff
but we've got this huge thing here um
another thing to not huge guy another
thing to note which is really important
uh in the leaked or the rumors earlier
there was talk of Miyazaki being uh
involved in this version not confirmed
in this at all that's right um he is
currently believed to be working on
bloodborne DLC so we don't know quite
what he's doing now it may be that he's
actually left bloodborne and doing
something else we're not quite sure when
you first heard that rumor you were very
doubtful weren't you yeah I was doubtful
about cuz he's the kind of guy I mean
fans of souls really dig into you know
what how Miyazaki is as a person and
he's the kind of guy that when he has a
project he really focuses in on that I
mean he was known for being quite
involved in the DLC for original Dark
Souls and and that kind of thing so it
would strike me as very unusual if he
abandoned Dark Souls to work on
something sorry bloodborne to work on
something else I reckon he would put a
full stop to bloodborne before he moved
on but having said that I mean the team
from software is grown significantly as
you can see they're working on two
products at the same time um so it may
be the case that he's kind of delegated
to his his you know underlings or second
in commands his underlings his Lord M he
wears the crown so you know he's like
make me a game so it maybe um he it
could come out soon I think Sony would
want to keep a lid on whether he's
involved right now because a lot of
bloodborne you know is being sold or
people are reacting to the fact that
it's a Miyazaki game you know there was
a lot of back Clash against Dark Souls 2
even though it was a good game like
people were saying that we can tell that
he wasn't involved in this so for him to
bounce this early from bloodborn would
be a bit weird for a lot of fans in the
series but still it looks good I'm
enjoying I enjoyed what I saw of it
evoked the similar themes and vibes from
the original Dark Souls and Dark Souls 2
so I'm excited I'm always up for another
Souls game oh yeah y Souls game Dark
Souls 3 come down the pipe at sometime
did they say early 2016 I believe at the
end of the trailer so look forward to
that next year now uh Ubisoft Ubisoft
took the stage they did at the Microsoft
press conference this year and uh even
with their own press conference coming
later this afternoon they showed off two
games the first of which was the
division uh of course this one we've
sort of it's been a few e3s running now
that we've been getting looks at this
and uh this one seemed to focus on uh
the people you know sort of talking
about being we thought this was going to
happen we they told us this might happen
we prepared you know we we prepared for
when everything we knew would just stop
happening and yeah being activated so
hinting at the lore of who are these
people who when Society goes bad just
start walking around with assault rifles
and trying to restore order I always I
always got the impression what I felt
like they were going for a kind of like
minimal law thing just create a world
and allow people to create the stories
within it in the same way that something
like Daisy does but it seems like and
it's not really surprising considering
the Tom clany series is based on quite
heavy narrative driven stuff it's it's
quite like interesting that they're
going for an actual story to tell when
the game play is kind of like open world
go around create gangs and find stuff so
yeah it it looks good though I really
enjoyed what I saw so far yeah and I
think that you know you talk about a
game like dayy or these games with more
emerging narratives those are sort of
heavily dependent on a multiplayer
component on their being Dynamic sort of
elements uh people creating their own
stories we certainly see in this trailer
that there are a lot of gas masked Thugs
who are very like very clearly visually
read as enemy however in years past
we've also seen uh competing squads of
human players depicted on the same map
there was no real hint of that kind of
multiplayer component to it here do you
think uh we're going to see that maybe
later at ubisoft's press conference or
yeah I reckon so yeah I I am almost
positive of that so all right well we'll
look forward to that we're going to have
a pre-show for that in just a little
while uh also they showed off Rainbow
Six Siege uh brief look at that which is
coming out later this year uh they
showed off maybe a new mode there was
some uh some bomb diffusing stuff but
only a glimpse at the two maps we've
seen thus far the airplane of course and
the house uh and really a look you know
I've played this game a bunch during the
the alpha the distinct operators really
really contribute to what sort of each
match feels like and which how it's
going to play out they didn't really
make a point of showing off new
operators that kind of granularity stuff
maybe seems more suited for their press
conference yeah also announced that
there was going to be some other Rainbow
Six games that come with it right or
that my imagination uh yeah so I think
they very much trying to draw the
comparison between this game and the
kind of like working together
Cooperative kind of thing and the uh
Rainbow Six Vegas games which were huge
on that with terrorist hunt and kind of
how difficult they were to play if you
weren't working together um so yeah this
those two games will be coming with this
with Rainbow Six Siege on Xbox one I
believe I I don't believe it was it's
going to be the same everywhere so I
think this might be a Microsoft only
deal well they made a point of saying
it's with the new backwards
compatibility thing that they're coming
so it's probably it's going to be
download codes and it's going to be that
same kind of code that you you know work
in the same way that the backwards
compatibility they announced earlier in
the press conference would work as well
Rainbow Six Siege coming out October
13th and for more on Siege and the
division we're going to look to our
Ubisoft press conference later today uh
then we had a a quick announcement of
after that we had a quick uh gig gtic
showed up on stage and this is now this
is the question I have for you guys what
is the name of this genre gigantic
OverWatch battleborn battlecry they all
are slightly different but they're all
sort of hero combat action oriented
combat the ter the term MOA sort of it
like hangs in their game design somewhat
but they're not really moas I think
they're closer to like team based uh
first person shooters like I think of
gigantic close being closer to Team
Fortress than um a traditional mobile
game obviously it's cribbing a lot of
elements well not a lot of like the the
kind of the hero elements of it and
putting it back into a Team Fortress
style blueprint I mean it doesn't have
mobs and creeps and that kind of thing
which are kind of at the heart of mobas
right yeah so I think that's what
distinguishes it from a classic MOA so
this is more like a A Team Fortress with
a Twist I reckon um and it looks really
really cool I mean gameplay wise it
looks fairly similar the the classes
seem to be very very much like the
traditional classes you would get
getting something like Team Fortress but
like the character designs are really
really cool I like the look of the kind
of the masked guy and the the arrow um
and bow and arrow character which is
cool and these little what like broccoli
demon broccoli demon looks Dragon I
think I described it uh during the
conference conference as like Pokemon
meets Team Fortress where you can like
throw out this one monster to do your
bidding for a little while and then just
call it away actually summon them from
like specific points in the map yeah
it's really cool I I like the style of
it great looks really nice and so a few
other stories here free to play and
across Windows 10 and Xbox One of course
with that Windows 10 integration there
is uh the the possibility for
crossplatform play and I think gigantic
is one of the first games confirmed to
have that M and that's going to be
available uh there's going to be a beta
for Gigantic in August and it's
exclusive to the PC and Xbox One next up
in the Microsoft press conference at E3
2015 was the Indie montage
and man did they just like blow through
about a dozen or so games really quick I
had a bad moment during that where I was
like oh that's cool that looks cool that
what's that one that looks neat uh but
then thinking like oh my God they're
just going to blow through this and not
show us in depth anymore fortunately my
fears were allayed when they did get
into uh sort of a bunch of sort of
highlighted Indie titles the first of
which was Tacoma from full and that full
bright of course the folks who made gone
home
Tacoma uh one of the sort of eerie sort
of exploration type games a little bit
in the spirit of gone home but
definitely a different setting yeah I
mean for bright absolutely fantastic
studio uh they opened up the the Montage
there were there were four Studios
weren't there that they're on stage I
think the eagy among you at home will
know that uh that Sony did the same
thing two years ago at their E3 show
they had like eight uh Indie developers
come on stage and talk about their timed
exclusive games uh and I thought you
know Chris Charlotte introducing these
four different games that are going to
be exclusive or timed exclusive to Xbox
one that was super
smart I'm curious here about this though
because at the very end it looks the
thing is I don't know American Sign
Language so I might be very I I don't
want to step on anybody's toes but it
looks like she's she's using ASL or
something similar she finger spelling so
my question is you know is is that in
gameplay or are we dealing with you know
in this case a a you know a a de
protagonist which really interesting
especially in light of a indie game they
showed a few demos later Beyond eyes
which the Creator or representative who
was up on stage described as uh wanting
to capture the experience kind of of
being blind this is a blind protagonist
and so she explores her world with other
senses and her world is illuminated in a
different way a very kind of watercolor
painterly way which really I mean shows
beautifully and reminded me of sort of
Echoes of ay and the blind forest's
appearance at last year's press
conference know it reminded me of The
Unfinished Swan as well a little
bit like a watercolor version of that it
looks absolutely beautiful doesn't it
yeah it looks really nice so that was
one another Beyond eyes another one of
the indie games showcased at Microsoft's
E3 press conference Ashen was another
and that was the sort of uh looked like
an exploration game you were third
person two characters who had uh blank
faces and so I mean this shot is just
lovely an evocative of sort of exploring
the ruins of something long past or of a
different scale and unfathomable sort of
thing uh but then in like just a minute
or two you're like okay cool this is
like a co-op game this dude totally gets
it he gets he gets skewered by a spear
but here we see some sort of Co-op
tropes uh what do you think Kevin you
Ashen intriguing you in any kind of way
it does intrigue me I just just because
I love the atmosphere I mean when I'm
looking at this the first thing I think
of is is uh ieko Eco from you know from
Team e so that's the vibe that I had at
first and then suddenly everything
started changing and it's like um this
isn't going to go so well and ouch yeah
yeah so I'm sort of curious about what
this place is um some you know this ruin
where maybe they've awakened these these
robots yeah and it's not every game demo
that shows you the death of one person
that you presumed to be the protagonist
or of during the demo but there you have
Ashen uh and then like rounding out that
Indie segment was one that we are all
just going bonkers for here cuphead man
you can't look at this thing in action
and not have a smile on your face it's
just Charming from like beautiful isn't
it yeah it's just look at it you can't
look at this game without smiling it
just looks incredible there's nothing
quite like it out there and why I really
like about it is mechanically at its
base it's really just like a a schmu
really isn't it yeah it looks I think
they also said platformer right so they
definitely want cuz well yeah you are
shooting but yeah a lot of it is
avoiding these sort of complicated
projectiles coming your way it does yeah
um points it just looks like you're
playing a cute version of iugo like like
here look at this having to dodge in
between Fireballs while they're covering
the
platform just look at it looks so good
it looks like it's going to be so hard
what was the release date announced it
was 1963 plus
20 1936 plus 80 years so it's coming out
next year 2016 but based on that old
timey 1930s cartoon aesthetic that's
cuphead rounding out Microsoft's Indie
showcase at the Microsoft press
conference here at E3 then moving right
along we got to uh Xbox game preview
yeah Xbox game preview Microsoft debuted
here it's their version of steam Early
Access are you glad to see something
like this come to consols I think it's
inevitable um and I think it's pretty
cool people some people want to play
games early and they can on I think I
think they're taking some of the danger
away from it by um allowing people to
trial a game before they decide whether
they want to commit and uh be a part of
that early development process or not
that's really really smart CU a lot of
the dangers of steam Early Access is
buying into a game which seems okay and
then finding out that it's actually
complete crap for like the next two
years and it
yeah what have I bought dang it but like
Hinterlands and Elite dangerous are
available today on the program so you
can go and check it out if see if you if
you want to play him and and commit
money to it then go for it you certainly
can yep now let's talk about the thing
that got us all the most excited I feel
like I there's no reservation in saying
this was like my most thrilling moment
of e3 thus far the hollow lens demo of
Minecraft oh oh my Lord oh wow
incredible I mean so we were talking
before the show about how uh Hollow lens
sort of has the advantage on VR because
you can rig up a special camera and then
see it in action and this table we see
here is where he sort of transfers the
game to and we're seeing it in action
and I still didn't want to believe it I
wanted to figure out like what is the
trick here how are they faking this but
Justin hawald our senior news producer
here was saying yep play it that's what
it looks like it is incredibly
and I mean is this is this basically
what you even even though Justin has
said it looks I still can't believe it
like it's it's it looks incredible like
the way he's just moving in into the
actual like the the uh composition of
the image and just looking around it
looks it looks insane I don't know how
they're doing it which is kind of the
best thing you can say about it it just
feels like magic and voodo that's
absolutely right I mean if it's anything
like this I'm going to have to get it
yeah it's it's is like and the best
thing is like like we were saying
earlier it's it's just completely
different from normal VR it's just so
different oh my God look at it I've I've
not played much Minecraft but man I am
looking forward to play I want to play
Minecraft I'm like I don't play
Minecraft now I want to play mft for
look me moving my fingers around and
doing this stuff and it's just I mean M
could they pick a a better game to demo
this with Minecraft is just sort the
spirit of play and exploration and it's
laid out there right in front of you and
that's really what you want when I think
when you have a new piece of gear like
you want it to be something that people
are excited to play to explore in and to
just kind of mess around with and this
kind of sandbox experience of Minecraft
the way that they've sort of calibrated
it to it just I'm just thinking about
all the stories how much positive praise
and press they got in the early days of
Minecraft for being like a really uh
interesting and intuitive tool for kids
to learn things like engineering and
that kind of thing building little
elevators and that kind of stuff and
then seeing this and just thinking man
they've just taken that to a whole new
level they could have this like in in
classrooms and that kind of thing where
kids Lear ex thing that's the exciting
thing this was just one demonstration of
what you could create with like with
this tool but like people are going to
create these incredible uh cre these
weird idiosyncratic Creations aren they
you could easily give this to like
surgeons and get them to do like trial
runs on surgeries and that kind of thing
like the applications of it now are just
mind-blowing obviously we're just going
to play Minecraft with it because we're
not that smart naturally I mean it's
like because this is so believably
awesome it really I'm thinking as you
guys are describing other applications
of the trailer they showed and it's like
oh I'm building I'm designing a
motorcycle I'm doing a power a
presentation I'm doing all this stuff
like it makes me a believer that that
stuff could work and be work well
because this works so well well I want
it to work as well yeah oh my goodness
yeah I want to believe I want to believe
I want to believe in holens holens
fascinating look at Microsoft's Hollow
lens playing Minecraft at Microsoft's
press conference here at E3 2015
and then of course Microsoft closed out
their press conference with one of their
big franchise we all knew it was going
to come Gears of War they said Gears of
War Ultimate Edition it's the original
gears remastered modernized coming out
on August 25th but it's Gears of War 4
that we saw the longer demo for Gears
four they've dropped the of War there's
no war happening there's just gears four
of themar four and uh it starts off and
it's a guy we don't really recognize in
a dark place and then he's with a woman
they are are they the new Marcus and Dom
marus Anda Marcus and Ana but I mean
she's playable right from the get took
till Gears of War I for Anya to take the
field uh but here we are it's very dark
right there we see there are two moons
and so I did a little Googling and
according to gears pedia there Sarah the
planet that gears T Gears of War takes
place on has only one Moon
so this could be a new planet obviously
they share some technology we see you
see the chaina
this shotgun The Nasher on his back
looks very familiar uh it looks it looks
really really cool I love I'm just
having flashbacks to playing the first
two gears games in Co-op and I'm just so
excited about it now um I never realized
how much I cared about gears until right
now like we're seeing it again being
like man I remember having so much fun
with gears I'm looking forward to seeing
more of it now and I mean expanded
fiction sure why not this is a chance
for them to actually try and tell a
better story I mean the first Gears game
had of the bunch had the most
interesting story of it because it was
laying out a universe and this had the
benefit of being the origin exactly and
if they treat this in a similar fashion
where they reset everything and kind of
draw a line underneath all the other
stuff that happened before and tell a
new gear story it could be an
opportunity to like go back to that
first era first game and have an
interesting story to tell don't touch
that don't touch that way that he
touches it he leans over
it right in his face uh in terms of you
know know new you were talking about new
fiction we also see new enemies so
perhaps uh instead of you know the
emolion inside the planet making Locus
and made these creepy like more
insectile enemies we saw right at the
end yeah I mean the enemies that we saw
like the the when it first popped up I
was like wow it looks like Rex from Mass
Effect
it I just want to hear the gear just s
like
krog as they shooting as he coming
towards him oh miss
Rex in fact we're in the same universe
looks just like Rex oh look at his teeth
except now except now yeah and the main
character T he looks just like BJ Basco
it's a bit like I remember people made
that observation that wow he looks like
BJ he does but yeah I like the UI looks
similar so it's kind of evoking the same
old Gears of War kind of familiar
feeling and I just think graphically it
looks fantastic it looks I mean the
gears games are always stunning to look
at and um chainsawing things is still
rad apparently yeah as you can see here
you guys sad to not see uh Doom style
dismemberment out of these chainsaw you
I'm okay I'm okay with it all right with
it a and with that tongue party in the
Gears of War guys or the gears four guys
face uh we're going to wrap up here our
post show coverage from Microsoft's
press conference 2015 at E3 we are going
to be coming back at you in just a short
amount of time let me check the schedule
here because we have got the EA press
conference coming up at 12:30 that's in
just 45 minutes uh we'll be back with
the pre-show and so please come join us
then get some food or whatever meal time
it is for you right now we're going to
go eat we'll be back to talk about EA
here live from Gamespot HQ at E3